[Musique]
bonjour jean claude duverger oui bonjour
et bon je vois tout ce qui nous est chef
de file d'ensemble pour une martinique
nouvelle à l'assemblée de martinique il
membre également du comité national du
ppm merci d'être avec nous dans son
caddie jean claude duverger nous avons
entre les mains
votre déclaration à l'attention de
l'actuelle majorité à la ctm vous leur
dites ça suffit mais tvo travail 13 mois
que vous dites ça tout 2017 sera encore
dans ce tempo de guerre à gaza y un
sénou qui fais autres cas des femmes en
fait c'est nous qui fait ça avant les
martiniquais vont se farcir ça encore
jean claude duverger pas du tout vous
avez bien compris que ce n'est pas de
notre faute nous avons passé cinq ans à
1 tonne que tout ce que nous avons fait
était prévu par eux ne l'ont pas passé
cinq ans en tant que tout ce qu'ils ne
font pas c'est parce que nous n'avons
pas fait ils l'ont dit en 2016 mais 2017
après une année logicien c'était
j'entends le conseiller exécutif charles
dire oui mais si nous n'avons pas fait
ça c'est parce qu'il y avait avant nous
y avait un nom il est temps de
travailler veut dire que premièrement
tout à l'heure j'ai attendu kolo barst
dit hélas ce pays mais les bons c'est
une très bonne musique mais pays à mener
dans la réalité on est là poivre si ils
disaient qu'on a bossé pas mon être et
de reculer mais un roi cunin comme il
recule de manière désorganisée
il bouscule tout sur le passage vendredi
dernier alfred marie-jeanne disent
encore qu'il a dû payer 62 millions de
dettes laissées par votre équipe
il n'a passé son année sa première année
de mandature à faire ça vous êtes
d'accord mais en fait moi je n'ai pas
fait une guerre avec un fouet mari
jaloux avec telle ou telle personne
chaque fois qu'il y a un problème il
faut de la 8
ils avaient dit qu'il y avait un déficit
et 1 arbitres qui est la chambre
régionale des comptes qui dit c'est pas
vrai vous avez menti et un défi il
continue à prades où cela nous avons
prévu de faire un lycée de transit
on n'a pas fait mais tout en étant sous
sous sous une dette importante
on va acheter des modulaires pour mettre
des enfants qui ont chaud qui ne sont
pas bien si tu essaies tu vas pas faire
partir des csp années un des bus qui ont
une assurance qui vont rester là une
année ça sera notre faute
alors cette complète à ses centres
récurrent des ducs emphatique tout le
monde
mais parler d'un arbitre la population
elle pourrait arbitrer mais la sortie de
plus en plus vous dites nous bon épisode
ce que je n'accepte pas ce que l'on me
dise que il y a deux can cocan
on n'est pas dans le caca c'est à eux
d'agir nous sommes une minorité là ils
prennent des positions seraient à peu
près 150
ils sont 33 ils sont 33 +9 plus sympa un
public c'est à eux d'agir
on n'a pas besoin de nous même si nous
ne voterons pas il faut passer le projet
qu est ce qu a dit que c'est nous qui
empêcheront mais simplement on va pas
accepter que nos disques on a un déficit
qu'on ne l'a pas on va pas accepter de
dire que lorsqu ils ne peuvent pas payer
quelque chose c'est la faute dans la
gestion
ce n'est pas vrai nous avons fait une
très bonne gestion des martiniquais
l'oissu on voit ce qui quand on parle on
dit voilà ce que nous avons et nous
avons fait telle ou telle chose
les pirelli s'offre et des martiniquais
qui s'offre centre du pays juste deux
exemples ses 130 salariés de l'afpa
humilié lâché livrent à leur sort
aujourd'hui
l équipe et d'être primé dans des
conditions tellement lointaine de ce
qu'ils ont occupé auparavant mais j'ai
fait un article autre jour dans le
progrès c'est je le disais mais je
n'attends rien
il y avait des loups ils sont devenus
des agneaux maintenant je voyais déjà
dans la rue mais ce cd martin qui
souffrent des martiniquais vont souffrir
aussi des taxes quoi y compris sous les
7 personnes ne diriez vous appeler la
population à ce je n'appelle jamais je
doit se révolter à s'indigner
jeudi 6 okapi j'ai crié pour savuka pigé
c'est ce qui se passe donc en plus pour
les personnes ne lave pas qu'ils
souffrent non sinon il faut que les
personnes de l'ap à 10 me situer
actionnerait parce que quand nous quand
nous disons qu'ils sont bien d'accord je
vais hébergé vous leur demandez de faire
entendre leur voix
il faut mais il faut entendre leur voix
il faut que légères comme les ja du sud
quoi les uns du sud n'ont pas attendu il
ya une augmentation des impôts les gens
dit écoutez nous ne pouvons pas
supporter cela
il y a des très belles souffrance tout
le temps il y avait des taxis on a
augmenté les sauces personne ne dit rien
je dis attention quand même
il faut que les gens disent nous
souffrons pas cosy à bosser les evo
contre l'incurie des politiques est
digne et vous parce que de la réalité
un honnête bloqués c'est une réalité a
pas de métier quand même que les
politiques
elle pose d'une sacrée musique sacrée
d'impôt la casse m
à propos du tcsp qui disait nous pouvons
rien faire et puis brusquement tana
jeanne rose quand nous sauter des
picadou bouteflika dit que varela qui
roule à partir de juin mais absolument
sa feuille appelé zapper fans et qui
sont nos amis mais tarbes et lannemezan
samedi aux compagnies en route pour
griller ou communautaires iny routes
nationales ou départementales les routes
municipales paix et porte-monnaie qui kg
ribao la paix est potes mais si vous
avez l'argent mais dès le départ ni
reconsidérer d'une part attendu au ps
l'âge comment tu veux que c'est ce que
veut dire il faut nous laisser à côté
nous ne parlons plus nous le disent nous
sommes là nous tu nous dis nous faisons
fait ce que nous disons fait l'essai au
cap à l'est puisque vous ressentez un
communiqué
mcafee en communication du chef de file
du groupe est de cacher votre écurie
derrière votre petit doigt parce que ce
matin j'ai entendu dire il y a des
problèmes ça peut arriver que l'on
puisse pas donner ce qu'il faut à telle
ou telle structure déception mais dire
que c'est parce qu'il ya eu un tel
bordel un 2007 à 2015 quoi code 2007
on n'a pas encore payé c'est fou quoi
c'est dire simplement nous avons trouvé
beaucoup de dossiers
et puis nous allons procéder ce qu'est
ce qu'il a dit à la fin nous allons
procéder cas par cas il nous est ce que
quelques dossiers à régler à février
pourquoi laisser un tel on est toujours
dans une campagne politique
alors qu il augmente comment comment
retrait du verger redonner ses lettres
de noblesse à la politique dans ce qu'il
faut y associer forfait il faut faire
mais je demande
je demande aux uns et aux autres de
revenir à 6,1 arrière qu'on nous accorde
nous avons pris le pouvoir en 2010 nous
avons réglé tout ce qu'il fallait régler
nous avons trois points qui aurait perdu
les élections alors est ce que oui mais
est-ce que ce que l'on a dit oui mais on
a prouvé que le musée ni paix rhdp show
n'était pas fini et apprécier la
mandature d'avant on a tout fait ouais
on a tout fait ce qu'ils avaient
commencé j'étais en dit qu'ils nous
disent voilà ce que nous avions commencé
que vous n'avez pas terminé
pourquoi que je peux le dire je ne peux
pas dire que nous avons dû passer de
laroche a produit ces transits
je ne peux pas dire que ils ont laissé
de côté le lycée 3 je ne peux pas dire
que ça ne s'est pas fait parce que
encore parlé du lycée schoelcher
longtemps écouté mais le lay a ouvert ce
lycée mais là sont accueillis m'en passe
entre chance mais je voudrais que le du
cciel cher ouais vivent tout le temps je
n'ai pas fini de parler il faut que ça
vive tout temps que tout cela est
occulté par les campagnes
présidentielles législatives
sénatoriales par cette notion de sao
faire plaisir je ferai du verger de
progressistes que tout le monde
revendique aujourd'hui à droite à gauche
de césaire latchimy en passant par
milliers par emmanuel macron justement
le progressisme de macron a séduit même
au sein d'ensembles pour une martinique
nouvelle
même au sein du ppe puisque certaines
vos camarades de vos compagnons céder
aux sirènes de ce mot vous en marche
alors que le parti d'être in elle avait
choisi de soutenir manuel valls et on
l'a appris pendant la nuit
il ya une procédure contre ses
compagnons qui ont choisi emmanuel
macron comment réagissez-vous reste
c'est normal ça veut dire ceux qui la
possèdent une normale
ce qu'ils n'ont pas fait autrement dit
on peut avoir des positions des deux
parties à la limite au contraire dans
les congrès dans les réunions dans les
conventions
ce sont des lieux d'échangés de
discussions et d'accords et de
désaccords un parti n'est pas un bloc
homogène simplement partie il y a des
possibilités des tabacs c'est tout cela
le même qui a des tendances
il ya une discussion à l'intérieur mais
quatre parties pour la décision prend
une décision il faut respecter la
décision du comité national ces
naissances qui dirige du comité national
donc la procédure consistera à clarifier
tous à éventuellement sanctionné d'un
bord je ne peux pas dire que l'on va
fonctionner puisque je connais pas le
comportement des ddd camarades du bac
mais je le sais latin c'est la claire
nette ils ont signé un document la
procédure ces deux des invités d'abord
on ne condamne personne sans les avoir
entendus d'éviter d'abord d écouter
entendre ce que disent les balises et
par rapport à cela
entendent ce que dit que que disent les
lilas mascaret les militants et les
sympathisants des instances qui existe
et puis après on fera un rapport sous
l'autorité de didier laguerre of war
rapport au comité national et qui compte
tenu de ce rapport va décider de la
suite va-t-on vers une scission va-t-on
vers une scission ceinture permet si
vraiment il y ait un désaccord s'est
passé pas simplement est-ce que
lorsqu'il y ait un désaccord
il faut que l'on parle
j'ai lu un texte sous ses airs dit j'ai
démissionné du parti communiste français
il est un désaccord communiste il
démissionne
lorsque mais ce n'est pas le cas l'un
avait dit qu'il faut les atteindre
maintenant s'ils disent nous voulons
partir nous gardons nos positions nous
allons prendre la parole ici et là et
c'était là nous soutenons c'est qu'ils
sont sous une autre ligne politique que
manière dont ils sont d'ailleurs sur toi
de vergers on a parlé beaucoup de frais
de lordinot daniel rubin eric hop est
daniel chomet et pourtant vous êtes bien
rester sur la présidentielle pourtant la
députation dans le nord bruno nestor
azérot candidats avec comme personne
dans son entourage et fluence dans la
campagne
norbert mousse teint troisième adjoint
maire ppm du maire ppm du quart béquille
entarté ppm
pas un mot sur lui deux poids deux
mesures il n'y a pas deux poids deux
mesures d'ailleurs vous m'apprenez la
nouvelle vous saviez pas je ne sais pas
ce que partout je ne sens que j'avais je
ne sais même pas qui est ce type les 1 2
2 qui n'est pas super beau c'est un
maire adjoint ppm au carbet sur l'âne
dans le comité d'organisation de la
campagne de boutonner stores a mené
contre justin pamphile le candidat
choisi ne sera laissé de côté catholique
est une procédure qui a engagé une
procédure qui serait engagé pour tout le
monde c'est un thème tout le monde
donnait la position du parti rien ne
sera laissé de côté c'est ce que voulait
le comité national s'agit pas d'un
président de secondaire c'est le comité
national merci d'avoir été ce matin avec
nom jean claude duverger rappelle que
vous êtes chef de file de l'opposition à
bmn à la soul et de martinique bonne
journée ok bonne journée à tous le monde
et merci de nous avoir écoutés
[Musique]